[Musique]
alors si tu as pas de nouvelles c'est
que c'est pas toi tu m'as rencontré
c'est bien ça
c'est comment la
allons-y vraiment il y a du monde au
casting pour mes cheveux
s'il te plaît
je m'appelle Hakim jemili j'ai 32 ans et
j'ai joué dans une série qui s'appelle
valider
que vous avez vous-même produit et
voulais m'écrire et pour laquelle je
n'ai passé aucun karting
alors aujourd'hui c'est une comédie
romantique ton partenaire de jeu va être
incarné par le ventilateur qui est juste
là
c'est bon
mais de quoi tu me parles
tu
le fais maintenant
tu tournes
stop stop stop stop tu as pas envie de
faire
le non il a rien du tout
[Musique]
alors c'est fadily Camara qui est drôle
c'est
oui
parce que sa femme je l'appelle frère
justement
deux trois
SA frère
[Musique]